s
intéresser à toi.
Il s'intéressait à l'autre.
Michel Bergeron je crois queer,.
- Bonsoir.
- C'est une immense perte. Cela
fait depuis huit heures ce
mesure mesure mesure mesure mest
parti du tissu de notre
imaginaire, de notre vie.
- Incroyable. Il a fait parti de
ma vie et ce matin, je devais
donner la conférence ce matin.
Quand j'ai reçu le téléphone,
en me disant : je ne vais la
prendre, je le savaisaitaitaitat
des mois qu'elle était malade et
qu'il avait souffert et je
savais que c'était cela. Les
souvenirs tout au ,
Guy a fait parti de ma vie
autant à Trois-Ru jouer à New
York avekagi est-elle
imparfait parfait.
Guy, c'était tellement une
personne agréable à côtoyer, pa.
Je le soupai avec lui et même à
New York, il m'appelait et me
jeudi. Je disais que je pouvais
Il est dit : ce n'est pas
plaisant. Guy aimait jouer.
Apprendre les systèmes de j
il a toujours joué par insti
et par patient, son talent lui
permettait de fair
talent... avant d'
talentueux, c'était un
travaillant. C'était toujours au
maximum nts.
C'est pour cela que Guy Lafleur
a été leader et de ses
coéquipin plus d'n plus d'n plue
la meilleure, c'était le plus
travaillant. C'était l'exemple.
Pour lesurs c'est
merveilleux.
- Les coach c'est Louis disait
tout à l'heure que quand il est
marqué par la veille, il faisaie
lendemain et le lancer de sat c.
Il était acharné.
- Absolument. Avec les Rangers
de New York, il avait fait
son... il est revenu avec moi.
Il voulait s'améliorer et je lui
disais qu'un moment donné, Guy,
la fraction de seconde qui n
différencie les superstars au
bonsoir, il l'avait perdu. Il
disait non. Des fo
- Parlez-moi de cela. C'est
quand même une h
incroyable. Il prend sa retraitt
déçu. Il est déboussolé pendant
quelques années. Là, il remonteé
cette chjouer dansjouer dansjoua
ervice queervice queervice queei
rendiez, il était capable encore
l'entraîneur... ce n'était pasee
m'a téléphoné, j'étais à Newnem.
Ils sont tous les deux : salut,
jeu. J'ai dit : ah oui.
Sérieux, un de mes amis m'avait
auparavant qu'elle avait vu Guy
jouer avec les anciens, fait que
j'ai dit : es-tu sérieux? J'ai
appelé mon patron et je lui
raconte cela.
Il dit :ew
York. C'est moi qui va les
chercher à l'aéroport. Je la
vois arriver à l'aéroport. Il
est beau est une forme comme Guy
Lafleur. Il s'entraînait pas
mais c'était un don de Dieu. Il,
je lui dis embarquer dans monchr
Phil. Phil le décompte veto
comme entraînement. Pas de
contrat. Tu dois te mériter la
place. Trois ans de retraite.
Crois-le ou non, Patrice, on va
à l'entraînement
On avait fait le camp
d'entraînement à Trois-
Rivières...
les journalistes du camp
d'entraînement étaient tous
rendus à Trois-Rivières pour
voir Guyemier
entraînement, le Colisée de
Trois-Rivières rempli.
ux au vent,
paf! Marqué le premier but du
camp d'entraînement.
- Bravo. Michel Bergeron, 30
secondes, qu'est-ce qui fait que
cet effort aujourd'hui? Qu'est-
ce qui fait qu'il attend
connecter avec les gens Québec?
- Sa façon de vivre. Il a jamais
refusé de donner un autographe,
jamais refusé de saluer les
partisans. Je pourrais te
raconter des histoires jusqu'à
demain matin de ce que j'ai vu
des Guy. Faire collaborer, faire
profiter ses coéquipiers aussi.
La générosité.
Lui, c'était droit comme un